hey herzlich willkommen zum best of
heute-show wahlen und parteien wir sind
tief ins archiv geklettert also ich
zusammen mit meinem guten freund und
kollegen lutz fand wie siehst du denn
aus
ich dachte wir kommen so wie wir auch
privat rumlaufen nur weil du dich seit
corona komplett gehen lässt heißt das ja
nicht dass ich auch keinen respekt mehr
vor mir und meinem leben haben muss und
vor den menschen da draußen für die ich
das hier eigentlich machen
aber du weißt schon dass wir hier im
studio keine klimaanlage haben
also wie gesagt body shaping klassismus
generell oberflächlichkeit also wenig
zutiefst ab deswegen war es mir auch
wichtig hier ein zeichen zu setzen und
hallo wir sind schon wieder drauf so
zurück zum thema best of wahlen und
parteien ich dachte wir fangen mit was
alte mann und zwar du bist so ein
drecksack echt jetzt die meisten leute
schätzen mich auf anfang mitte dreißig
gut ich meinte jetzt zwar einfachen
alten beitrag aber du hast glück dass
videos so alt dass du dann eben richtig
frisch aus ist stark was denn an sorry
ich merke das sind zwar richtig frische
comedy talente im video
hazel und beatrix von storch daneben
siehst du doch alt aus die afd ist im
bundestag ein schwarzer tag für
deutschland einer von uns muss zur afd
der andere zur cdu
[Musik]
hallo guten abend wie wäre das ergebnis
wohl geworden wenn merkel wahlkampf
geführt hätte vielleicht sogar ein
bisschen besser aber mit diesem ergebnis
was wir haben können wir sicherlich
nicht zufrieden sein also stimmen sie
mir zu dass sie keinen wahlkampf geführt
hat sie hat den wahlkampf geführt aber
ich glaube die umfragen waren deutlich
besser
in welchem land haben in deutschland
tatsächlich die waren vor vier bis fünf
wochen tatsächlich ein bisschen besser
als die jetzt welche partei die cdu
tatsächlich das habt ihr das mitbekommen
zufrieden mit dem ergebnis
was hoffen sie für die zukunft der
demokratie und freie meinungsfreiheit es
ist tatsächlich im augenblick noch eine
männerpartei ist also es gibt halt ganz
viele frauen den doktortitel haben und
dann gibt es ganz viele männer die sind
die absolut größten holzköpfe die ich je
gesehen genau und männer selbst das ist
gerade so fast wie ein sinnbild der afd
dass ich hier eine sehr intellektuelle
frau mit kulturmagazin habe und ein mann
aus zwickau der an allen brot kaut wie
erklären sie sich diese differenz
zwischen männern und frauen in der alten
interessenten in prototypen
für einkommensteile seien bei dir
gesperrt haben die ganze team morgen und
volksabstimmungen durch die zwei punkte
dann sind wir schon zufrieden ausbauen
aber sie sind jetzt auch eigentlich in
mitleidenschaft gezogen wurden von einer
geschlossenen grenze sie wollten gerne
daran was essen und dann haben sie nicht
eingelocht erinnerung können sie ja das
ist erinnerung könnte
setzen sie all ihre hoffnungen auf
merkels nächsten türkei-besuch ich
glaube das wird so schnell nicht nennen
aber dann würde sie vielleicht verhaftet
werden und sie wären das problemlos aber
es ist ein problem offensichtlich ja gut
da haben sie jetzt geschickt mir die
worte im mund verdreht
ich bin nicht mitglied eröffnete ich bin
also ich treffe mich eigentlich hier mit
einem freund das hat mir gedacht ich
hätte mir das ganze mal habe ich war
gerade da vorne
nein ich bin ich ein gebiete also sie
treffen sich am sonntag vor der afg
party location in einem afd blauen hemd
mit einem freund ja es ist das ist
eigentlich zufall das blaue hemd
party im endeffekt und ich habe leider
kein anderes blaues hemd zu hause
deswegen habe ich es dass sie sind gegen
eine koalition mit der fdp könnten sie
doch auch kaputt koalieren wie sie das
mit der fdp und der spd gemacht haben
nein das geht ja nicht bezahlt ja wieder
das dauert ja wieder was das
zusammenkommen
rainer zeiten des rechtspopulismus sind
auch zeiten für die linke satire
was ist ihr persönlicher humor mein
persönlicher humor in mitglied auf
linkspopulisten oder was auch immer sie
unter humor verstehen und sage jetzt
einen witz machen wenn sie möchten sehr
gerne
also ich mach mal ein witz die kanzlerin
ist immer noch nicht zurückgetreten das
ist doch eigentlich ganz schön witzig
oder ja ich würde sagen
hier haben sie das publikum für diesen
witz gefunden viel erfolg beim opener
ist in bezahlen
dann hätte ich ein setup kommt die
kanzlerin zum arzt
helfen sie mir wie geht's weiter sagt
der arzt
hier ist aber dreckig ich glaube ich
brauche eine putzfrau die schwarz
arbeitet
was kann ich denn konkret machen sie die
öffentlich-rechtlichen besser zu
gestalten wie so ein interview wie heute
mit ihnen ja also sie waren einfach ins
fernsehen kommen und dann ist koran ich
will nicht ins fernsehen kommen aber so
ein faires interview wo nicht die haken
fragen gestellt werden wo hinter der ein
großer große publikation gemacht wird
also nicht dass ich sie jetzt in sachen
frage wie ist es nicht wirklich so dass
nicht nur nazis die afd wählen sondern
auch einfach idioten genau das würde die
frage gefallen würde die sind leider zu
oft gefallen
[Musik]
hessel ja nimmst du mich mit in die
schweiz
nein wir nehmen keine ausländer
nazi das war übrigens mein erster
beitrag mit hessel zusammen und was
viele nicht wissen ich setze mich privat
ja sehr sehr sehr sehr für frauen in den
komischen künste nein
nur wer das von einer clownschule das
ist eine clown akademie nein ich bin
eigentlich bei frauen in der ganzen
branche dafür bekannt dass ich also wenn
ich mein tipp habe eine anmerkung
konstruktive kritik dass ich dann per
whatsapp sprachnachricht video message
auch mal mitten in der nacht ein agent
der fuchtel da hinten so nervös war man
wird aber auch so schnell missverstanden
heutzutage ja das ist übrigens zufällig
eine gute überleitung zu unserer
nächsten reportage
da war ich bei den grünen und die grünen
die fühlen sich auch kraß missverstanden
weil alle sagen heidi klum hat sandalen
wieder cool gemacht obwohl es eigentlich
anton hofreiter war ja vor allem weil
wir so laut lachen wenn die partei der
wissenschaft kiloweise globuli frist die
grünen haben zwei fehler gemacht erstens
sie haben die homöopathie debatte
verschoben und zweitens sie haben mich
reingelassen
ich bin aus der zukunft gekommen heute
und habe die homöopathie debatte dabei
[Gelächter]
unschön überraschend viele bei den
grünen finden also mittelchen gut deren
wirksamkeit nicht belegt ist und die nur
ein placebo effekt beinhalten müssen die
dann das klima paket der bundesregierung
nicht auch gut finden wie gar nicht also
auch ein placebo effekt ist ein effekt
wer heilt hat recht es meinung es
funktioniert einfach
sie laden die homöopathie lobby bezahlt
die homöopathie lobby klavier gibt es
einfach nicht es gibt starke lobby gegen
die überzieher aus meiner sicht sie
glauben dran glauben es funktioniert
einfach also ich persönlich glaube
überhaupt nicht wo ich bin selber
naturwissenschaftler
ich glaube nicht so aber es funktioniert
trotzdem aber metro glaubt ja was sollte
die krankenkasse noch finanzieren ein
schornsteinfeger für jeden zum anfassen
aber wenn ich daran glaube dass das
glück bringt es wurzel markt der völker
katze ist kennt man ja mach mal die
hände auf ich habe für alle globuli
dabei
[Musik]
in 2
ich habe mir nehmen sie den streit in
die grünen tragen wollen dann treten sie
hat sind grünen baum dann streiten uns
ja aber gegen dieses angebot nämlich
globuli ich dachte die helfen da schon
aber gestritten wird doch immer noch
also hier hinten geht es dann ab oder da
können wir den klimawandel nicht einfach
verschieben
wer cool also ich würd mal sagen wir
schieben einfach mal angeschrieben die
erde ein paar zentimeter reck und dann
wird es kühler
gegen schlechte witze habe ich übrigens
auch globuli dabei da ist nix war schon
bei uns hat nix also wird geklärt wie es
gehört dass es ordentlich aussieht aber
nicht thema wird zur seite geklärt und
es wird das wird jetzt erst mal die
richtigen räume gebracht und zu
diskutieren und dann kommen die bäume
die außerhalb der öffentlichkeit statt
muss man denn überhaupt diskutieren bei
etwas wo es wissenschaftlich erwiesen
ist dass es über den placebo-effekt
hinaus nichts bringt entweder ist man
die partei der wissenschaft oder nicht
natürlich immer die wissenschaft es gibt
so eine liste ohne wissenschaft nicht
all das sagt die afg beim thema klima
auch in so eine wissenschaft und so
nation
das ist so lichtjahre von den zweck es
ist ganz geile zeug ich sage mal so
volker beck war es zu krass jetzt
interessiert nein also meine drogen zeit
habe ich in der jugend hinter mich
gebracht
es war eine sehr intensive und gute
erfahrung das hat mich auch
weitergebracht glauben sie denn
vielleicht auch heilsteine oja man muss
ihn nur fest genug laufen
da sieht man doch noch die alten grünen
hervorkommen klare stadtbahnen wissen wo
sind die guten alten zeiten den nicht
man früher da hatte ich noch angst vor
ihnen echte band ist aus dem tiger ein
kätzchen geworden das passiert immer so
mit der zeit liegt nicht am arsch ist
dass hier nach harmonie soße ich geh
jetzt zur kühlers und fragt ob sie noch
drogen führt die so richtig ball an den
hammer ich war mir jetzt nicht sicher du
wolltest 400 globuli einen kaffee nicht
dass der jetzt zu süß ist ich habe auf
dem dreh übrigens so viele von den
zucker kümmerlichen geschluckt ich
konnte danach acht tage lang nicht
schlafen aber stuhlgang war okay was
entschuldigung da ist irgendwas in
deiner art dass mir immer das gefühl
gibt ich hätte es mit sehr sehr kleinen
kindern zu tun
ja und warum bringst du mir da wie
schokolade mit oder mal was zum spielen
weil liebe dich weich macht fabian und
dass da draußen ist eine kalte und
herzlose lädt und ich will ich ich will
einfach mich dass du immer noch dass
lauterbach trauma ich habe ihn weich
gemacht
es war einmal ein junger mann namens
karl ein mann ein karl dem kein traum zu
klein war
der nach den sternen greifen wollte mach
es karl habe ich gesagt ich glaub an
dich karl karl ich liebe dich nutzt van
der horst alles was er anfasst landet
bei der wahl zum spd parteivorsitz auf
dem drittletzten platz
ich hasse mich
[Musik]
kassel
wir von der heute-show wir wollen sie
pushen wir pushen sie wir bringen sie
nach vorne wir bringen sie richtig nach
vorne nur uns ja klar
darum tragen doch die fliegenklatsche
also sie auch dann neben dem navi
großzügig sind jetzt dabei was habe ich
ja keine andere wahl
[Musik]
sie mir vielleicht mal die anderen
kandidaten kurzen nennen ich habe mich
nur mit lauterbach beschäftigt christina
kommt man mit michael roth dem matthias
und glücklich saskia esken dynamik ist
heute angesagt also wir sind hier quasi
in jeans hose turnschuhe die dynamik
bringen wir mit in die halle
sie sind jung sie sind hipp was machen
sie in spd
also hier halt kann man jetzt schon mal
ausschließende dieser reaktion das
stimmt es gab ja leider auch die eine
oder andere spaß bewerbung wie stehen
sie dazu
also ich hätte mich gefreut wenn es ja
ein bild mann geschafft hätte ich mein
olaf scholz kandidat im ganzen feld dann
klarer geist von olaf scholz dass sie
tiere nicht kennen ja der mensch haben
sie eigentlich ein paar tipps von martin
schulz bekommen also ob dieser hilfe
sind in der jetzigen lage sei
dahingestellt tipps tipps haben wir
bekommen ja immer das gegenteil machen
dann könnten sie hilfreich dass schon
kommentierte jan tipps bekommen das ja
klar ist dass klimapolitisch nicht das
völlig falsche signal wenn total
aussichtslose kandidaten jetzt
wochenlang durch die republik reisen
ich feiere bahn also haben sie sich auch
angesprochen gefühlt weil stränge
geschlagen
sollte ja mal gesehen ja
bundespräsidentin werden
irgendwann ging nicht
sie werden jetzt doch sie werden doch
dann doch doch noch doch doch so einfach
ist es uns schon fertig haben sie war
dein chef liege und machen werbung für
den richtigen machen da irren sie sich
verliebt war ja da war ich und das ist
ob das denn wer toll sie hat freiwillig
die kriege angezogen sie ist
übergewechselt in das lager zu karl
lauterbach und das ist mutig verschwand
lassen sie mich das sagen das ist mutig
da gab es natürlich eine fliege lesen
klartext mutig nein das ist völlig und
sie nicht gerade sagen wir haben doch
alle ähnliches ziel und insofern sollte
am selben ende vom strick ziehen mit den
anderen vom strick ist auch ein schönes
bild sprang am stricken sie haben bei
der spd nicht regulieren das tut er das
ziemlich fest
[Musik]
wahnsinn wie cool und lustig gesine
schwan rüberkommen wundert mich gar
nicht dass die bei der spd nichts mehr
zu sagen hat
er ist halt eine arbeiterpartei wenn da
jemand lässig und lebensfroh ist denken
die anderen sofort warte mal da stimmt
was nicht die wurde ja gar nicht vom
kapitalismus gebrochen und das erklärt
natürlich die schwitzende männlichkeit
die olaf scholz so populär machen
absolut da denkt man immer der geht nach
dem job noch zwei stunden in den keller
und arbeitet mit metall mit edelmetall
hat goldstaub ist auch staub ok genug
geredet über den einen deutschen top
anwärter auf die kanzlerschaft
aber es gibt ja noch diesen anderen
typen armin laschet den habe ich 2017
beim nrw wahlkampf begleitet und damals
haben sogar die eigenen leute von der
cdu nicht dran geglaubt dass er gewinnt
während heute bevor ich zu gleich zwei
wahlkampfveranstaltungen der cdu fahre
spreche ich erstmal mit den betroffenen
den menschen im stau in nrw wie schlimm
ist es ekelhaft in paris ist ein stau
wir haben wir kurz warum sie beim thema
stau ist dass selbst fahrende auto die
lösung weil dann könnten könnte das auto
eigenständig im stau stehen und sie
nehmen die bahn also die haben die
eigentümer also einen scherz namen spiel
viel schneller ist die verkehrslage zu
lassen würde würden sie nrw dann
verlassen sollte ich das nicht sagen wir
mal ich mag weil es gar nicht geht sie
würden ja im stau stehen das ist auch so
leider wir fahren jetzt zur cdu die
partei die in nrw endlich alles besser
machen will obwohl das gutes an nicht
straßen müssen sie zumindest nicht ran
weil die sind schon ganz okay also man
kann fahren
[Musik]
straßenbau fehlt halt noch das waren die
gelder nicht an fordert bayern ruft
immer hier den namen die gelder also
einfach mal hier ruf lecker mal zusammen
hier rufen ja hier hier hier hier auch
mit die veranstaltung ist ja heute hier
von der senioren-union gibt es denn
überhaupt eine andere union
es gibt wäre die frauen-union die junge
union die mittelstandsvereinigung und
dann die cd ist sie meinen die frauen
senioren union die junge senioren union
es gibt rede vereinigungen das heißt
frauen union
die senioren-union die junge union wie
die senioren union ja frau merkel
erinnert sich nrw auch immer an die
letzten tage der ddr ist unsere fragen
ganz klar kommt mir sehr wichtig die
kanzlerin zu sehen wollte
um unser leben geht okay ich habe jetzt
ein bisschen angst bekommen sind welcher
hinsicht angst es geht um unser leben ja
um die ewigkeit und die ähnlichkeit
schützen sie nicht hier nein warum auch
warum aufgenommen also können sie denn
wer gar nichts positives an einlasse
drin
er hat charisma wie ein stück holz
okay das ist aber die anderen haben wir
momentan stark mache ich die mal nicht
gelaufen wir aber dann wäre der laschet
naja kommen will
herr laschet haben sie kurz zeit nur ein
kurzes statement
herr laschet nrw geht es schlecht die
bildung ist im eimer wirtschaft ist im
eimer
was muss noch alles passieren bis die
cdu endlich den richtigen kandidaten
aufstellt jetzt flüchten sie doch nicht
von mir ein kleiner euro1080 brachten
lassen
schnell aber die straßen sind doch so
schlecht da kriegen die reifen schnell
so wenig profil gelöscht oder specials
armin bis bald mach's gut
[Musik]
man man man so schnell geht die zeit rum
wisst ihr noch als wir vor 15 minuten
los gezogen sind in diesem lustigen okay
es waren auch zwei videos von fabian
dabei also als hier vorgeführt 40
minuten los gezogen sind wobei meine
videos waren dafür ja extrem kurzweilig
muss man sagen oder weißt du noch wie du
mal acht tage lang nicht aus seiner
garderobe rausgekommen ist weil hier
irgendjemanden spiegel an die wand
gehängt hat gerüchte das war nur vier
tage ja also ich fand es nett dass wir
mal wieder was zusammen gemacht haben
weil weil du dir nach all den jahren
immer noch was bei mir abgucken könnte
neben weil die leute vom catering sich
einfach viel mehr mühe geben wenn biber
wie du dabei ist das auto vom koch hat
zufällig vorher gefasst nur zufällig war
ich da und der espresso der war laura
das machen eine frechheit gefreut
eine absolute frechheit hast du recht
so leute ihr wisst alle was jetzt
passiert ihr schaut noch vier oder fünf
lustige videos dann kickt der
algorithmus rein und zack seid ihr
querdenken der impfgegner von der flat
society die ihren rundfunkbeitrag nur
noch in reichsmark zahlen ja und deshalb
wie kann man seine letzten stunden als
mündige mitglied dieser gesellschaft
besser verbringen als jetzt noch alle
unsere videos zu leiten und den kanal zu
abonnieren
zack zack zack ach so und noch mehr zum
lachen gibt es natürlich auch comedy
punkt zdf.de ja aber nichts zum elfter
september oder zu adreno crew schwierig